ينضم الينا من القاهره الى الفنان وصلنا
على المحتوى احمد البشوتي احمد يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك نورنا بصباح العربيه
لماذا اخترت النقد لاذع مغلف بالكوميديا
الساخره للحديث عن قضايا المجتمع
يعني انا بعتبر
الكوميديا اكثر اكثر كوميديا ممكن توصل
لقلوب الناس هي الحاجه
المتعلقه بالحاجه اللي بتحصل لهم يوميا او
الحاجه يعني فكره ان انا اجيب حاجه مثلا
من على التيك توك او غير واعمل رياكت
عليها باحس ان دي يعني مش مش كوميدي قوي
الكوميديا اللي متعلقه اللي بتمثل البني
ادم غلاء اسعار همم
الجو مثلا الناس اللي بتحب الصيف الناس
اللي بتحب الشتا المصايف الحاجه اللي
بتمثل يعني همم دي اكثر حاجه بتبقى قريبه
القلب فلما اخذها بالمصري كده باقول بنقلش
عليها او بنسف عليها ف- اا دي بتوصل للناس
وبالتالي اكثر كومنت بيعجبني يمكن من
الناس لما لقى الناس بتقول احنا اللي انت
حكيته ده بيحصل معنا بالضبط فباحس ان انا
وصلت للترجي بتاعي طب احنا
ايه هو الحل لغلاء الاسعار على طريقه احمد
البشوتي
ههه
[موسيقى]
يعني زي ما احنا قلنا كده الفلفل الالوان
بلاش منه خليه ابيض واسود
البانيه يعني الفراخ ما نشتريش فرخه كامله
نشتري ورك مثلا يعني بقدر الامكان نقتصد
في الموضوع ما نشوف بقى الدنيا ماشيه ازاي
ونحاول نضبط امورنا يعني طيب احمد انت
حضرتك شعبيه كبيره في الوسط الشعبي
الكوميديا صخره هي محتوى صعب مش اي حدا
يقدر ينجح فيه
بصي هو حته ال ال المواطن العربي بوجه عام
والمواطن المصري بوجه خاص صعب جدا تضحكي
يعني سهل جدا تجيبي له اكتئاب او تخليه
يعيط تحكي له حادثه او تحكي له عن الاسعار
او عن الاوضاع الاقتصاديه اللي بيمر بها
العالم كله عامه فهتجيبي له اكتئاب بسهوله
جدا في 5 دقائق ودمعته تنزل على خده انما
عشان تضحكي المواطن العربي او المصري دي
تبقى حاجه صعبه جدا ففكره ان انت توصلي له
من خلال شاشه وتخليه يضحك من قلبه على
همومه همم دي حاجه تبقى صعبه وانا يمكن
باستمد حاجه زي كده من الراحل ال- ال-
العبقري الاستاذ نجيب الريحاني همم يمكن
هو اللي ابتدع المدرسه
الكوميديا السوداء الضاحك الباقي او
المضحك المبكي ازاي ان هو كان بيتريق او
بيسخر من اوضاع اللي موجوده ويخلي الناس
في عز ما هي زعلانه وبتعيط بتضحك على
همومها فانا باستمد من روحه العظ طبعا
الكوميديا دي زي ما قلت لك صعب قوي
التحكيم في الوطن العربي المصري بالذات
الكوميديا سوداء يعني تسليط الضوء على
مواقف وازمات بيعاني منها البلد طب احمد
انت بتشوف نفسك في مستقبل القريب ستاند اب
كوميديا شو الطريق اللي رسمها لك خصوصا
بعد هذه الشهره الحقها تاع السوشيال ميديا
[موسيقى]
همم
بشوف نفسي ان شاء الله باذن الله همم وده
اللي انا باطنه عليه ان انا اخش اعمل
تمثيليه ان شاء الله يعني لسه ما فيش حاجه
تعرضت بس ان شاء الله انا كل امل في ربنا
ان في حاجه تتعرض علي همم تبقى باحب
الحاجه دي الحاجه اللي متعلقه بالكوميديا
الخاصه بالمواقف همم
ان شاء الله يعني باتمنى من ربنا يكون ده
المستقبل القريب باذن الله والغناء همم
مغني محترف كمان
بحب الغناء جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني انا
بحب الكوميديا اولا والغنى او الغنا او
انا بعدين يعني بحب الغناء بشكل غير طبيعي
شهره ونجميه اللي انت بدك اياها على كل
حال نورتنا شكرا على وجودك معنا من
القاهره الفنان وصانع المحتوى احمد باشوتي